[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs merci de nous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro dédié à vos idées sorties
tout de suite le sommaire de ce vendredi
1er décembre top départ des festivités
dans les yvelines marché de noël et
journées spéciales sont prévues pour
préparer le jour j produits gourmands
artisans locaux et animations pour les
enfants le point sur les différents
événements organisés ce week end on
partira au pays du père noël avec
techsoup un petit ours qui a des envies
de voyage en laponie pour retrouver son
grand père mélanie nous présentera cet
ouvrage dans notre rendez-vous junior
dix septième édition de la fête du conte
à saint-quentin-en-yvelines histoires et
comptines investissent les médiathèques
du réseau jusqu'au 10 décembre
une invitation à venir rêver en famille
à ça y est enfin le mois de décembre ce
matin vous avez sûrement ouvert la
première case de votre calendrier de
l'avent noël n'est plus que dans
quelques semaines il faut préparer sa
lettre au père noël
amani la moune boîte aux lettres
spéciale a été installée dans le hall de
la mairie
elle a été réalisée par les jeunes du
service jeunesse la ville récupère les
lettres jusqu'au 23 décembre et des
transmet au père noël qui répondra
personnellement chaque année plus de 2
plus de 200 enfants lui écrive à magny
les hameaux
vous avez jusqu'au 23 décembre pour
déposer la vôtre ce week-end marque le
top départ des marchés de noël celui de
montigny le bretonneux aura lieu jusqu'à
dimanche 3 décembre à la ferme du mas
n'est plus de 130 stands de produits
alimentaires et d'artisanat sont prévues
sans oublier le père noël toujours
fidèle au poste et la grande roue
nouveautés de l'an dernier qui revient
pour cette 26e édition la grande roue
peut se pratiquer en famille entre amis
la participation est d'un euro minimum
et au profit du téléthon
l'année dernière nous l'avions déjà eu
ce marché noël et au profit du téléthon
nous avons récupéré 2410 euros donc
c'est aussi participer à une belle
oeuvre dans la grange nous avons les
artisans et cette année dont 80 artisans
seront présents et 30% de percer
d'artisans nouveau et merci amical et
demi d'euros d'avoir recueilli ses
propos
ce week-end le marché de noël c'est
si à elancourt sur le parvis de l'hôtel
de ville des structures gonflables et
une piste de luge eux feront le bonheur
des plus jeunes et pour la première fois
coignières organise aussi son propre
marché rendez vous samedi de décembre
sur la place de l'église saint germain
d'auxerre
un concert de chants de noël aura lieu à
18h pour clore cette journée en musique
et on reste sur cette thématique mais
dans un lieu un peu particulier avec
notre invité les gourmands et les
curieux ont rendez vous ce samedi au
potager du roi de versailles une journée
spéciale fêtes de fin d'année vous
attend avec un marché et des produits du
potager plus de 450 variétés fruitières
et 400 variétés de légumes
ils sont cultivés l'occasion de
découvrir quelques raretés ou
originalité le responsable nous a mis
l'eau à la bouche nous sommes au potager
du roi avec son responsable
antoine jacobson ici tout s'organise
pour la journée spéciale fêtes de fin
d'année du samedi de décembre
grosse préparation car vous allez
accueillir de nombreux exposants vous
allez faire découvrir vos produits tout
à fait c'est quand même la troisième
quatrième fois que nous le faisons on a
un certain nombre d'habitudes ont un
certain nombre de exposants habitués ça
va du produits alimentaires comme les
cressonnières d'ile-de-france à des
artisans du bois
là c'est concrètement c'est un
architecte paysagiste de l'école qui
fait des petits ouvrages des petits
objets en bois qui sont formidables des
très bonnes idées de cadeaux juste avant
plein d'idées cadeaux alors qu'est ce
que vous allez présenter vous au potager
du roi quels seront vos produits nous on
va produire on va produire les a déjà
produit on va présenter nos racines
on va présenter nos revendeurs de
produits divers ça va à la fois du
produit frais aux produits transformés
en produits frais on va présenter duo ko
ou dia qu'on le loquace et une tubercule
des andes qui est un peu acide ressemble
beaucoup plus petit que la pomme de
terre mais à quelque chose de
ressemblant
le yak ans c'est tout autre chose c'est
une sorte groot d'hercule qui ressemble
un peu physiquement à comment dire à une
patate douce mais la peau est pas la
même couleur et qui a des saveurs
on va dire texture de poires avec un
goût de plus comme la pomme de terre
donc c'est assez intéressant
on peut faire des choses formidables
avec c'était chose un petit peu méconnu
rares il ya même des produits si un
petit peu oublié c'est une vraie volonté
du potager du roi de faire découvrir ou
redécouvrir tous ces produits là alors
j'aime bien le mouv redécouvrir ce que
méconnu oui c'est des choses qui ont été
connus si longtemps on les aurait pas on
n'est pas les seuls à en faire les
vraies questions aujourd'hui sont les
redécouvrir pas juste pour une question
de saveurs pas juste une pointe question
on va dire de d'insolites et de
surprises sur une table mais aussi parce
que nous sommes dans ici chez nous au
potager du roi mais aussi ailleurs dans
des recherches de rotation culturale de
deux systèmes de production où nous
avons besoin d'une plus grande diversité
pour baisser la pression des maladies la
pression des ravageurs pour mieux gérer
l'enherbement tout ça sans produits
phytosanitaires ou sans traitement et
tant mieux et dans les produits
transformés parce que là on a parlé
beaucoup des produits frais mme dans les
produits transformés il ya des
confitures beaucoup de confiture et
autant de la du confit de sarriette ya
vraiment des saveurs assez
exotique si on peut dire alors le confit
de sarriette ses secrets sont confiés
mais moi j'ai tendance à l'utiliser dans
pour des sceaux présente comme un pot de
confiture
moi j'ai tendance à l'utiliser par
exemple pour dans une vinaigrette
on a aussi des choses qui sont vraiment
dans le sucre est quelque chose un peu
insolites ou moins bien connu une
confiture de la flotte qui est un fruit
marron comanche blettes et que beaucoup
de gens n'aiment pas parce que parce que
on sait pas quoi faire avec on fait des
confits nous on le traite en confiture
et tous les gens qui adorent qui aiment
la crème de marrons adore il faut
surtout en profiter samedi pour
découvrir le domaine un quart des
visites guidées sont proposées au public
le matin et l'après midi
donc on va faire deux visites un peu
particulière tant une à 11 heures où ce
sera le 1 des jardiniers l'adjoint
responsable l'adjoint responsable
adjoint qui va faire donc chargé de la
production de la transformation qui va
faire un tour du jardin avec un de nos
partenaires qui s'appelle charles cracco
qui est l'un des fondateurs d'une jeune
société qui s'appelle mademoiselle saint
germain qui utilisent certains de nos
productions pour faire des produits de
soins parce que ça aussi c'est une idée
cadeau pas que alimentaire on peut à
trouver des produits de soin d une crème
de beauté une crème hydratante fait à
partir des produits du potager du roi à
cette occasion et donc souvent pour les
balades en extérieur on imagine que
c'est plutôt pour les beaux jours la
belle saison mais ici se passe beaucoup
de choses
en hiver il ya beaucoup de choses à voir
même pendant la saison froide quels sont
les travaux vous effectué par exemple je
j'ai envie de reprendre ce que vous
dites et est allé même un peu plus loin
avant de répondre parce que oui c'est
que c'est ça l'intérêt de ce jardin
ce n'est pas qu'un jardin à voir ces
pages simplement un jardin objets où il
faut le voir à son meilleur moment
il ya un meilleur moment qui est
probablement entre juin et septembre
j'admets mais c'est un jardin dans
laquelle quelque chose se passe tout le
temps et ce quelque chose c'est
précisément ce qu'on veut transmettre
c'est qu'est ce qu'on fait dans un
jardin hiver qu'est ce que ces convois
dans un jardin d'hiver
comment est-ce que ce jardin qu'on voit
à ce moment là donnent des témoins de ce
que ça deviendra précisément à cette
époque ci encore plus précis que ça
mardi donc journée spéciale le samedi
mais le mardi 5 me décembre nous allons
faire une plantation de plus de 100
mètres linéaires de haies fruitières
diversifiée pour nous aider à conserver
nos formes fruitières et pour augmenter
notre production
c'est vraiment une saison on va dire de
changement structurel des plantes
novembre et début décembre et à partir
de décembre nous commençons la taille la
taille des fruitiers
nous allons
nous n'avons plus de 4500 et ce travail
là va durer jusqu'à fin février même au
début mars
donc là on est pile dedans à découvrir
le travail des jardiniers du potager du
roy à découvrir même l'hiver et à
découvrir samedi de décembre merci
beaucoup antoine jacobson donc on le
rappelle cette journée spéciale de fêtes
de fin d'année du potager du roi c'est
samedi 2 décembre
alors pour l'occasion d'accès au potager
sera au tarif exceptionnel de 1 euro
vous avez voulu rendre la chose
accessible et vous êtes donc attendus
samedi de décembre de 10h à 17h toute la
journée
[Musique]
direction le grand nord pour notre
rendez-vous junior mélanie vous allez
nous parler d'un roman jeunesse
on part en laponie avec techsoup un
petit ouf qui a des envies de voyage
dans ce pays du nord alors on suit ses
aventures dans cet ouvrage un ours au
pays du père noël un livre jeunesse de
véronique barbotin pour l'histoire
l'auteur qui vit à rambouillet nous en
dire un peu plus
c'est un petit tour ça qu'il arrive une
aventure un petit peu particulière
puisqu'y eelv a souhaité retrouver son
grand père en laponie et donc avant de
préparer son voyage il va passer par la
bergerie par exemple de rambouillet donc
on reste en même temps dans le local
avant de partir pour le grand voyage en
laponie un texte assez court qu'on peut
dire petit à petit avant d'aller se
coucher
un os au pays du père noël est destiné
aux enfants à partir de 6 ans et
pourquoi pas des quatre cinq ans en
lecture avec les parents et les
illustrations sont signées michel breton
un artiste pastelliste c'est vraiment
une rencontre où j'ai vraiment
l'impression qu'à chaque fois que
j'écris quelque chose michel comprends
tout à fait ce que j'ai voulu dire
et honnêtement le personnage de
de techsoup a été inspirée de
l'association dont je vous parlerai mais
on est parti vraiment sur quelque chose
où les postures de textes où c'était
vraiment moi j'ai pas le talent de
michel pour pour dessiner et à chaque
fois lui on a l'impression que ça y est
c'est le prolongement crayon de demande
de cesser vos stylos cet ouvrage a aussi
un but caritatif
est-ce que 20 véronique barbotin et
michel breton ont décidé de reverser
leurs droits d'auteurs et
d'illustrateurs à l'association louis
carles et 6 mo alors cette association a
dead apport pardon une aide
psychologique et matérielle aux enfants
est gravement malade elle organise des
voyages en corse en guadeloupe à la
réunion elle fait aussi des spectacles
avec des clones pour les enfants qui
peuvent pas quitter l'hôpital mais aussi
d'organiser des rencontres avec les
stars qui font rêver les enfants
de quoi se faire plaisir tout en faisant
plaisir merci beaucoup mais il anime
vous avoir présenté les aventures de
textos en laponie
le livre est disponible aux éditions pg
com on va rester dans les histoires car
je sais que vous adorez ça mais la villa
17e fête du conte à saint quentin en
yvelines jusqu'au 10 décembre petits et
grands sont invités dans mon lit une
histoire
mercredi dernier à la médiathèque
jacques brel le magny les hameaux les
spectateurs se sont envolés pour
l'espace la tête dans les étoiles
ce soir là quand le soleil s'est couché
quand la nuit est apparu
les animaux regarder dans le ciel ils
ont vu apparaître
c'est l'histoire de notre planète et de
l'univers qui nous entoure
comptines dessin et théâtre permette au
plus petit d'aborder l'espace avec
albert 112 j'aime bien piocher dans
d'autres techniques artistiques en
d'autres ressources artistiques comme le
sillage de la jonglerie l'origami ni
c'est un public que j'aime bien moi
j'apprécie ça fait maintenant près une
dizaine d'années que je raconte pour ce
public
ce qui me plaît dans le tout petit basse
et ils sont à côté spontané ils sont
vraiment présent il faut du coup être
vraiment présent avec eux
[Musique]
aussitôt qui plaît il écoute
et si les contes s'adressent beaucoup
aux enfants pas question d'oublier les
adultes c'est pour tous les âges c'est
ça qui est génial c'est ça qui me plaît
aussi dans star là c'est que le conte
traditionnel il ya déjà le contrat du
style s'adresse vraiment il ya toujours
dans les contes traditionnels différents
niveaux de lecture et des cons qui sont
plus adaptés pour les enfants mais à
l'origine la tradition orale s'était pas
spécialement pour les enfants c'était à
la veillée se raconter des histoires il
ya toujours niveaux différents niveaux
de lecture et c'est ce que j'essaie de
faire dans le sind en mai spectacle quoi
même pour les tout petits à voir les
petits clins d'oeil les petites choses
qui font rire aussi des adultes pas
d'âge pour rêver se laisser embarquer
dans la fête du conte de 50 ans nos
villes jusqu'au 10 décembre les
médiathèques du réseau et les lieux
partenaires vous invitent à voyager
[Musique]
magie dans ses repas partagé ce soir
participer à la veillée villageoise de
maurepas organisé par l'association mort
pas d'hier et d'aujourd'hui c'est la
treizième édition le thème ce soir les
années 70 alors enfilez votre plus belle
tenue disco le 7-8 loisirs est
maintenant terminé merci de nous avoir
suivis je vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro je vous
souhaite un excellent week end
il